[Musique]
cela fait désormais un an qu aucune
session plénière du parlement européen
ne s'est tenu à strasbourg
c'est une atteinte au traité européen et
au principe de l'europe polycentrique au
coeur même de l'idée européenne 2020
aura été l'année au cours de laquelle le
monde faisait la mer découverte de la
cua vite 19 2021 sera celle des variants
ce n'est donc plus face à une épidémie
que nous devons nous battre mais au
moins deux et pourtant par manque
d'anticipation rien ne semble vraiment
la hauteur de l'enjeu
après le manque criant de masques de
protection qui a poussé le gouvernement
à remettre en cause leur efficacité
après les lacunes du traçage des cas
contacts après l'échec de la stratégie
de dépistage et la trop lente montée en
puissance de la capacité de tests pcr
après le décollage poussive de la
campagne de vaccination
après les listes d'attentes des
personnes de plus de 75 ans rendement de
se faire vacciner
liste qui ne cesse de s'allonger voici
le nouvel épisode de la saga des défaut
d'anticipation du gouvernement la
pénurie de kits de séquençage du génome
du virus sascoc 2 mais les français ne
corrompt ne comprennent pas votre
stratégie de vaccination
pas d'anticipation dans les commandes
des vaccins des organisations des
centres de vaccination listes d'attentes
interminables je souhaite vous alerter
sur les conséquences de l'interdiction
des pratiques sportives depuis le mois
de mars 2020 une vraie lassitude
s'installe chez les jeunes et les clubs
craignent des arrêts massive de
pratiquer à court et long terme
partout en france nous constatons des
violences envers les élus locaux les
agents de service public
policiers et pompiers agents municipaux
nous en avons assez de ces agissements
lâche et indigne
que comptez-vous enfin faire propre
protéger les élus de la république
devient maintenant huit ans nos forces
armées sont déployées ou seul le courage
l'abnégation et la compétence de l'eau
soldats ont permis d'y remporter de
nombreux succès militaires
est empêché la constitution d'un
sanctuaire islamistes les défis à
relever restent cependant considérable
comment supporter que les hommes et les
femmes exceptionnelles de nos armées
soient les seuls en europe à payer le
prix du sang
nos agriculteurs face aux défis
qualitatif mais aussi quantitatif ont
tout fait pour nous nourrir sur les
marchés dans tous nos magasins
rien n'a jamais manqué et pourtant la
profession n'a jamais autant souligné
les écueils de la loi et galim notamment
en termes de fixation des prix
le compte n'y est pas l'incompréhension
gronde au moment où l'on appelle à
consommer local et que dans le même
temps en ré ouvre les dossiers des
traités internationaux du mercosur et du
ceta d'énormes inquiétudes planent sur
les étapes décisives de négociation de
la future pac qui se déroule
actuellement
pour madame et dont l'état ne pouvons
pas lutter efficacement contre la
délinquance dans certains secteurs de
notre pays
il vaudrait mieux démissionner vous avez
annoncé que le maintien à domicile de
nos seniors et est votre priorité bien
l'objectif au regard des 80% des
français qui y sont favorables
encore faudrait-il que cette ambition
soit accompagnée de moyens la médecine
c'est un métier de vocation les
étudiants dans cette période difficile
montre combien ils sont impliqués
d'ailleurs dans la crise est vraiment il
faut leur laisser de l'espoir
il ne faudrait pas que la réforme du
numerus clausus soit moins bonne que
celle qu'elle était initialement prévu
il faut véritablement que vous fassiez
un effort important tant sur le plan
financier que sur le plan
organisationnel pour que nous ayons la
capacité de véritablement assurer
l'avenir du canal du midi
[Musique]